Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. music perhaps by shirley bassey perhaps by adele or perhaps knowing my co-presenter dominic sandbrook by duran duran then poor mccartney and wings surely a familiar theme strikes up we're looking down the barrel of a gun dominic appears from the right of the frame dressed in a smart black tuxedo strides across a white background before bang he swivels and shoots the camera holding the pose red trickles down cue stylized title card which reveals the words the rest is history welcome to the show
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。音乐或许是雪莉·贝西（Shirley Bassey），或许是阿黛尔（Adele），又或许，了解我的联合主持人多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）的话，那应该是杜兰杜兰乐队（Duran Duran）。接着，保罗·麦卡特尼（McCartney）和羽翼乐队（Wings）那熟悉的旋律响起，我们正处于枪口之下。多米尼克出现在画面右侧，身着考究的黑色燕尾服，大步走过白色背景，随后——砰！他转身向镜头射击，保持着姿势。鲜血缓缓流下，紧接着出现风格化的片头卡，上面写着“历史的余味”。欢迎来到本期节目。
Dominic um do you fancy yourself as uh as James Bond I actually to be honest I see you so see you as more a kind of le carré figure tom lurking in the background everything about that introduction has been quite offensive from the sort of erotic tone with which you did my bond like appearance to then the implied comparison with george smiley and of course the truth is we all fancy ourselves as james bond don't we but if you ever read those smiley books and there's that sort of description of him the sort of shabby man in the Mac trudging from library to library in the pouring rain. I mean, that basically is the life of a historian. But you see, I wouldn't even be George Smiley. I'd be so useless. I'd miss all the key clues and kind
多米尼克，嗯，你觉得自己是詹姆斯·邦德吗？老实说，我更觉得你像勒卡雷（le Carré）笔下的人物，汤姆，潜伏在背景中。刚才那段开场白里的一切都让人感到冒犯，从你描述我那“邦德式”出场时那种色情的语调，到后来暗示我像乔治·斯迈利（George Smiley）。当然，事实是我们都幻想自己是詹姆斯·邦德，不是吗？但如果你读过那些斯迈利系列小说，里面对他的描述是：一个穿着破旧雨衣、在倾盆大雨中从一个图书馆蹒跚走到另一个图书馆的邋遢男人。我的意思是，这基本上就是历史学家的生活。但你看，我甚至连乔治·斯迈利都算不上。我太没用了，我会错过所有关键线索，然后……
of end up shot by Carla in some back street or something. However, fortunately, we do have as our guest today, and our theme, as you probably guessed by now, is history of espionage, history of spying. We do have someone who knows pretty much everything there is to know, not about the fiction of spying, but the reality, even though his books are in many ways more gripping than fiction. And it is, of course, Ben McIntyre, author of Agent Zigzag, Operation Mincemeat, Spy Among Friends, among many others. One of which, Ben, was The Spy and the Traitor about Oleg Gordievsky. And I name check that because it was the most recent of your books I read. And I read it last year in a wintry St. Petersburg. And it was the perfect fit of subject
最后在某条后巷被卡拉（Carla）射杀之类的。不过幸运的是，我们今天请到了嘉宾，正如你们现在可能已经猜到的，我们的主题是间谍史、情报史。我们请到了一位几乎无所不知的人，他了解的不是虚构的间谍故事，而是现实，尽管他的书在很多方面比小说更扣人心弦。他当然就是本·麦金泰尔（Ben McIntyre），《特工之字形》（Agent Zigzag）、《肉馅行动》（Operation Mincemeat）、《朋友间的间谍》（Spy Among Friends）等多部作品的作者。其中一本，本，就是关于奥列格·戈尔季耶夫斯基（Oleg Gordievsky）的《间谍与叛徒》（The Spy and the Traitor）。我提到这本书是因为这是我读过的你最近的一部作品。去年我在寒冷的圣彼得堡读了它，那真是主题与地点的完美契合。
matter to location. So Ben, thanks so much for coming on to The Rest is History. Delighted to be here. Thank you so much for inviting me. I'm looking forward to this. We've been talking about both James Bond and George Smiley and I guess for us in Britain, there is a risk that we tend to see the history of espionage almost entirely in fictional terms. Do you think that's true? I think it's true. I think it's also true that there is a strange and enduring link, I think, between British fiction and espionage, because it's no accident, I think, that many of the greatest novelists of the 20th century were themselves spies. You've mentioned Ian Fleming and John le Carré. They were both in the intelligence, but there are many more.
所以本，非常感谢你来到《历史的余味》。很高兴能来到这里。非常感谢你的邀请。我很期待这次谈话。我们一直在谈论詹姆斯·邦德和乔治·斯迈利，我想对于我们英国人来说，有一种风险，就是我们倾向于几乎完全从虚构的角度来看待间谍史。你认为这是真的吗？我认为是真的。我还认为，英国小说与间谍活动之间存在着一种奇怪而持久的联系，因为我认为，20世纪许多最伟大的小说家本身就是间谍，这绝非偶然。你提到了伊恩·弗莱明（Ian Fleming）和约翰·勒卡雷（John le Carré）。他们都曾在情报部门工作，但还有更多人。
Somerset Maugham, John Buchan. There are, I mean, almost, it's an uncanny link, I think, because I think in lots of ways the work of espionage is not so far removed from the work, from what novelists do. You try to imagine an artificial world, and you try to lure other people into it. And the better you are able to frame this artificial imaginary world, the better spy you're going to make. Graham Greene's another brilliant example. They all learned the trade of fiction, I would say, through espionage. So I
萨默塞特·毛姆（Somerset Maugham）、约翰·巴肯（John Buchan）。我的意思是，这几乎是一种不可思议的联系，因为我认为在很多方面，间谍工作与小说家所做的工作并没有太大区别。你试图构想一个虚构的世界，并试图诱导其他人进入其中。你构建这个虚构世界的能力越强，你就能成为越好的间谍。格雷厄姆·格林（Graham Greene）是另一个绝佳的例子。我会说，他们都是通过间谍活动学会了虚构的技巧。所以我……
think it's no accident that the two are, particularly in British culture, deeply intertwined. In fact, funny enough, I thought it was rather telling in a way that when Stella Rimmington stepped down as head of MI5, the first thing she did was to start writing novels. Well, but you know, actually it was Luke Jennings, am I allowed to say that? Who wrote it? Who then went on to write Villanelle.
认为这两者之间有着深刻的交织，特别是在英国文化中，这绝非偶然。事实上，有趣的是，当斯特拉·里明顿（Stella Rimmington）卸任军情五处（MI5）负责人时，她做的第一件事就是开始写小说。嗯，但你知道，其实是卢克·詹宁斯（Luke Jennings），我能说这个吗？是他写的？后来写了《杀死伊芙》（Villanelle）。
I hope I'm not betraying too many secrets there. You've shattered the illusion. But Ben, doesn't that then raise a question? So if you think about a book like Graham Greene's Ant-Man and Havana or Le Carre's The Tailor of Panama, which is kind of inspired by that, there's a sense that the whole thing, I mean, without giving those books entirely away, there's a sense that the whole thing, I mean, without giving those books entirely away,
希望我没有泄露太多秘密。你打破了幻觉。但本，这难道不会引发一个问题吗？如果你想想格雷厄姆·格林的《我们的哈瓦那人》（Our Man in Havana）或者勒卡雷的《巴拿马裁缝》（The Tailor of Panama）这类书，后者在某种程度上受到了前者的启发，你会感觉到整件事——我的意思是，在不完全剧透这些书的情况下——你会感觉到整件事……
there's a sense that the whole thing is a fiction, that the spy is selling a fiction to their superiors, a fiction of what's happening in the country, but also a fiction of their own influence and the fiction that spying matters. I mean, does it matter? I mean, lovely that you mentioned Our Man in Havana because, of course, Our Man in Havana
你会感觉到整件事都是虚构的，间谍在向他们的上级兜售一种虚构，关于这个国家正在发生什么的虚构，也是关于他们自身影响力的虚构，以及关于间谍活动本身很重要的虚构。我的意思是，这重要吗？我的意思是，很高兴你提到了《我们的哈瓦那人》，因为当然，《我们的哈瓦那人》……
is directly based by Graham Greene on a real intelligence case. It's based on the Garbo case. Now, the Garbo case was this extraordinary double agent in the Second World War. His real name was Juan Pujol. He was a failed Spanish chicken farmer, believe it or not, who turned up in Britain. Well, he was actually brought to Britain by MI5 in the end. And he invented an entire sort of army of sub-agents. He ended up with 23 people, each of whom had a different backstory and wives and so on, all of whom were completely invented. And they were used to feed back very, very important disinformation to the Germans on the eve of D-Day. Now, Graham Greene knew about this story. And so he absorbed this, what seems like a, I mean, and Garbo himself was
是格雷厄姆·格林直接根据一个真实的间谍案件改编的。它基于“加博”（Garbo）案。现在，“加博”案是二战中一位非凡的双重间谍。他的真名是胡安·普约尔（Juan Pujol）。信不信由你，他是一个失败的西班牙养鸡户，后来出现在英国。嗯，他最终实际上是被军情五处带到英国的。他虚构了一整支下属特工军队。他最终拥有了23个人，每个人都有不同的背景故事、妻子等等，所有这些人都是完全虚构的。他们被用来在诺曼底登陆前夕向德国人反馈非常、非常重要的虚假信息。现在，格雷厄姆·格林知道这个故事。所以他吸收了这一点，这看起来像是一个……我的意思是，而且加博本人就是……
a failed novelist. I mean, that's what he really wanted to do. So he created this fictional world, which then had a direct impact on reality, and then became fiction again afterwards. So the makey-uppy stuff that he was doing during the war changed history and then became fiction again. I mean, another great example is the Operation Mincemeat story, again, which I've written about, which wonderfully sort of started as a sort of mad idea in the mind of a group of intelligence officers who were all frustrated novelists or poets. I mean, what they did was to create an entirely false identity for this dead man, who then was shipped onto the coast of Spain and had a dramatic and very important effect on the invasion of Sicily, because it helped to convince the Germans the attack was actually
一个失败的小说家。我的意思是，那才是他真正想做的事。所以他创造了这个虚构的世界，然后对现实产生了直接影响，之后又变回了虚构。所以他在战争期间所做的那些“编造”的事情改变了历史，然后又变回了虚构。我的意思是，另一个伟大的例子是“肉馅行动”的故事，我写过这个故事，它奇妙地始于一群情报官员脑海中一个疯狂的想法，他们都是失意的小说家或诗人。我的意思是，他们所做的是为这个死人创造了一个完全虚假的身份，然后被运送到西班牙海岸，对西西里岛的入侵产生了戏剧性且非常重要的影响，因为它帮助说服了德国人，认为攻击实际上……
coming in Greece. Now, that was revealed as a novel by Duff Cooper after the war, because he wasn't allowed to publish it as reality. And then once it had become a fiction, then one of the authors of the plot was allowed to turn it into a real book, which then became a film, The Man Who Never Was, which then became a nonfiction book in my case, and then is about to be a film again. So the weird interplay between the two continues. But to answer your question, most espionage doesn't make an enormous amount of difference. That seems a strange thing to say from someone who has written now, I think, something like 12 books on espionage. But because most espionage cancels itself out.
即将发生在希腊。现在，这在战后被达夫·库珀（Duff Cooper）揭露为一部小说，因为他不被允许将其作为现实出版。然后一旦它变成了虚构，该阴谋的作者之一就被允许将其变成一本真实的书，后来又变成了电影《死而不亡》（The Man Who Never Was），后来在我的案例中又变成了一本非虚构书籍，现在又即将再次被拍成电影。所以两者之间奇怪的相互作用仍在继续。但回答你的问题，大多数间谍活动并没有产生巨大的影响。对于一个现在已经写了我想大概12本关于间谍活动书籍的人来说，这似乎是一件奇怪的事情。但因为大多数间谍活动都在相互抵消。
We know what they know that we know that they know that we know. And where you are on that kind of strange continuum is kind of where you're winning or losing in the spy game. Macmillan was always of the view that we should just get rid of all spies completely or indeed just tell everybody everything. And then there would be no problem. But but very. And usually what espionage does and espionage is itself a rather loaded word. But but what the sort of spy game does is that it oils the wheels of traditional diplomacy. It allows access sometimes to important information that makes us safer when it works and makes us radically more unsafe when it doesn't work. I mean, so let's think of the Gulf War.
我们知道他们知道我们知道他们知道我们知道。你在那种奇怪的连续体上的位置，就是你在间谍游戏中赢或输的地方。麦克米伦（Macmillan）一直认为我们应该彻底摆脱所有间谍，或者干脆把一切都告诉所有人。那样就不会有问题了。但是……非常。通常间谍活动所做的——而且“间谍”本身是一个相当沉重的词——但间谍游戏所做的，是为传统外交润滑轮子。它有时能获得重要的信息，当它起作用时让我们更安全，而当它不起作用时让我们变得极其不安全。我的意思是，让我们想想海湾战争。
I mean, you know, when intelligence is privileged beyond what it is worth, it can be catastrophic. But very occasionally, it does have a strategic impact on the way states behave. And Operation Midspeed is a good example. The D-Day deception is another very good example. I mean, without the success of that spy operation, would the Normandy landings have worked? Well, possibly. Would there have been greater budget? Absolutely, certainly. Ben, just for the benefit of those who are not familiar with either of those operations,
我的意思是，你知道，当情报被赋予超过其价值的特权时，可能是灾难性的。但非常偶尔，它确实会对国家的行为方式产生战略影响。“肉馅行动”就是一个很好的例子。诺曼底登陆的欺骗行动是另一个非常好的例子。我的意思是，如果没有那个间谍行动的成功，诺曼底登陆会成功吗？嗯，可能吧。会有更大的伤亡吗？绝对，肯定的。本，为了那些不熟悉这两个行动的人，
could you just sketch out exactly what those two operations are? Both in the Second World War, and they're both, as you say, kind of almost fictional projects designed to deceive the Nazis into thinking something's going to happen that doesn't. With pleasure. I mean, in order, Operation Mincemeat was an attempt to persuade the Germans that instead of landing in Sicily, the great Anglo-American armada that was setting off from North Africa, that instead of aiming for Sicily, which was the obvious target, that whole flotilla was heading for Greece. And it was a very complicated general deception plan. But the key element of it was what sounds like a completely bonkers idea, which was to get a dead body. And in fact, the idea, here's another link, comes from Fleming. Because Ian Fleming, when he was assistant to the head of naval intelligence, was asked to come up with a list of ruses, one of which he produced something called the Trout Memo. And the Trout Memo was so-called because he compared catching spies and the whole work of espionage to fly fishing. And number 51
你能简要概述一下这两个行动到底是什么吗？都是在二战期间，而且正如你所说，它们都是某种近乎虚构的项目，旨在欺骗纳粹，让他们认为会发生什么，但实际上并没有。乐意之至。我的意思是，按顺序来说，“肉馅行动”是试图说服德国人，那支从北非出发的英美大舰队不是要登陆西西里岛——那是显而易见的目标——而是整个舰队正前往希腊。这是一个非常复杂的总体欺骗计划。但其关键要素是一个听起来完全疯狂的想法，那就是弄一具尸体。事实上，这个想法——这里有另一个联系——来自弗莱明。因为伊恩·弗莱明在担任海军情报局局长助理时，被要求列出一份计谋清单，其中之一就是他制作的所谓“鳟鱼备忘录”（Trout Memo）。“鳟鱼备忘录”之所以这样命名，是因为他将抓捕间谍和整个间谍工作比作飞钓。而第51条……
in this list of totally mad ideas was, let's get a dead body and drop it somewhere where the German spies will find it, because a dead body is more believable than a living person. And so they did exactly that. They got hold, they found, totally illegally, they found a dead body in a warehouse in King's Cross. They turned him, his real name was Glindore Michael, but they turned him into someone completely different. They turned him into a major in the Marines, and they equipped him with a uniform and a backstory and everything that you would if you were a novelist. And also with key counterfeit papers, letters from senior commanders that indicated quite clearly
在这个完全疯狂的想法清单中是：让我们弄一具尸体，把它扔在德国间谍会发现它的地方，因为尸体比活人更可信。所以他们确实就是这么做的。他们弄到了，他们完全非法地在国王十字车站的一个仓库里找到了一具尸体。他们改造了他，他的真名是格林多·迈克尔（Glindore Michael），但他们把他变成了完全不同的人。他们把他变成了海军陆战队的一名少校，并为他配备了制服、背景故事以及如果你是小说家会准备的一切。还有关键的伪造文件，来自高级指挥官的信件，非常清楚地表明……
that an attack was looming in Greece and that the Sardinian campaign was a complete feint. And they took this body and they shipped it ashore on the coast of neutral Spain, where they knew that a particularly effective German spy was operating. And it worked. Astonishingly, because of the Bletchley Park intercepts, you can follow this lie as it goes from the south coast of Spain to Madrid,
攻击即将在希腊发生，而撒丁岛的战役完全是一个佯攻。他们带着这具尸体，把它运到了中立的西班牙海岸，他们知道那里有一个特别有效的德国间谍在活动。而且它奏效了。令人惊讶的是，由于布莱切利园（Bletchley Park）的拦截，你可以追踪这个谎言从西班牙南海岸传到马德里，
Madrid to Berlin, Berlin to Hitler's headquarters, and then straight down the gullet of the German high command. And it worked. I mean, they moved considerable numbers of troops from one side of the Mediterranean to the other. So that's the bizarre Operation Mincemeat story. And the other one, perhaps even more significant, was the one surrounding the D-Day deception, which involved the use of double agents. They were the key elements in this. Now, these were people that
从马德里传到柏林，从柏林传到希特勒的总部，然后直接进入德国最高统帅部的喉咙。而且它奏效了。我的意思是，他们将大量的部队从地中海的一侧调到了另一侧。所以这就是那个离奇的“肉馅行动”故事。而另一个，也许更重要的，是围绕诺曼底登陆欺骗行动的那个，它涉及使用双重间谍。他们是其中的关键要素。现在，这些人是……
the Germans had sent to Britain to spy against the British, who had been picked up by the British and either executed and then impersonated or turned or otherwise used to feed information back. And the bizarre thing about that was, again, because of Bletchley Park, the British were able to intercept not just some of the German spies that were coming to Britain, but all of them, every single one, bar one, character, there's one remaining mystery. There was one particular Dutch agent who parachuted into Britain who went by the unimprovable name of Engelbertus Fucken. And Engelbertus Fucken has never been...
德国人派往英国去监视英国人的，他们被英国人抓获，要么被处决然后冒充，要么被策反，或者以其他方式被用来反馈信息。而其中离奇的事情是，同样，因为布莱切利园，英国人能够拦截的不仅仅是来到英国的部分德国间谍，而是全部，每一个，除了一个，角色，还有一个未解之谜。有一个特定的荷兰特工跳伞进入英国，他用的名字是无可挑剔的恩格尔伯图斯·法肯（Engelbertus Fucken）。而恩格尔伯图斯·法肯从未被……
That wasn't his code name. No, that was his real name. God knows what his code name was then. That's such a Bond film name name was then i mean what a gift to a novelist but but so he was found engelbert i'm going to say it again engelbert as fucking he's found in in a in a in a in a bunker in cambridge and nobody knew how he got into britain without being caught they put a real panic through mi5 because he was the only one but otherwise they captured a lot of them and they they used them. And Garbo was an example that we talked about at the top of the cast. But there were a
那不是他的代号。不，那是他的真名。天知道他的代号是什么。那真是个邦德电影里的名字……我的意思是，给小说家的一份大礼。但他是在剑桥的一个地堡里被发现的，没人知道他是怎么在没被抓到的情况下进入英国的。他在军情五处引起了真正的恐慌，因为他是唯一一个，但除此之外，他们抓获了很多人，并且利用了他们。加博就是我们在节目开头谈到的一个例子。但还有……
whole set of others. There were five essential ones. And they used them to send information indicating this time that the obvious target, which was Calais, was the target. So it's the reverse, if you like, of the Sicilian deception. And again, what it did was it buttoned up large numbers of German troops in Calais, waiting for an invasion that never happened. Now, it's almost impossible to quantify what impact that would have had. So you're in the, because what if history doesn't, there's never really worked. But you know, it is perfectly reasonable, I think, because you can see the troop deployments that it has, it's one of the very few occasions when intelligence goes straight into strategic thinking, that it actually materially affects and changes the way people behave. I mean,
一整套其他人。有五个核心人物。他们利用他们发送信息，这次表明显而易见的目标，也就是加莱，才是目标。所以如果你愿意的话，这与西西里岛的欺骗行动正好相反。同样，它所做的是将大量的德国军队困在加莱，等待一场从未发生的入侵。现在，几乎不可能量化这会产生什么影响。所以你处于……因为如果历史没有……从来没有真正起作用。但你知道，我认为这是完全合理的，因为你可以看到部队的部署，这是情报直接进入战略思维的极少数场合之一，它实际上实质性地影响并改变了人们的行为方式。我的意思是，
you mentioned Gordievsky as well, Tom. I mean, that's another one of the rare ones that really did actually materially impact Western policy towards the Soviet Union. So you mentioned Gordievsky, and your two examples are kind of Second World War examples. But the thing that the conflict that most people think about with spying is the Cold War. I mean, the Cold War is in many ways defined by spying. You know, Bond, Le Carre, the sort of spy who came in from the cold. And do you think spying mattered in the Cold War as much as it mattered in World War Two? If you're measuring mattered by actually having an impact on the way states behave,
你也提到了戈尔季耶夫斯基，汤姆。我的意思是，那是另一个罕见的真正实质性影响西方对苏联政策的例子。所以你提到了戈尔季耶夫斯基，而你的两个例子都是二战的例子。但大多数人想到间谍活动时想到的冲突是冷战。我的意思是，冷战在很多方面是由间谍活动定义的。你知道，邦德，勒卡雷，那种从冷战中走出来的间谍。你认为间谍活动在冷战中像在二战中那样重要吗？如果你通过实际上对国家行为方式产生影响来衡量“重要性”，
I think not really, because of course, the Cold War was cold. I mean, it was never it never, it never actually led to to what it did in certain areas, but it never led to direct conflict. So, so while it was hugely extensive, far more extensive, the espionage of the Cold War era than anything that was going on in the Second World War, and there's something delightfully amateurish, really, about the way it was done in the Second World War. It became much more professionalized. It became much better funded. Did it have a profound impact? Rarely, I think. But that question may not have been fully answered yet, because of course, a lot of the material, a lot of the archival material is still closed up. But there are,
我认为并不完全是，因为当然，冷战是“冷”的。我的意思是，它从未……它从未……它从未真正导致……它在某些领域确实导致了，但它从未导致直接冲突。所以，虽然它是极其广泛的，冷战时期的间谍活动远比二战中发生的任何事情都要广泛，而且二战中那种做法确实有些令人愉快的业余。它变得更加专业化了。它得到了更好的资助。它产生了深远的影响吗？很少，我认为。但那个问题可能还没有得到完全的回答，因为当然，很多材料，很多档案材料仍然是封闭的。但有……
I mean, and Gordievsky is a very good example. I mean, that's a really good example of a spy who was able to inform his masters, in this case, MI6 and the CIA, able to inform them what the enemy was thinking. And that's the critical element of espionage. If you can get inside the head of the opposition and not only find out what he's doing, but what he's planning to do, you're a big step ahead. What Gordievsky did, Gordievsky was a career KGB officer. I mean, he'd been born into the KGB. He was a very good KGB officer, in fact. He sort of came with the blood, really. But in Copenhagen in the 60s, he turned. And he turned really almost entirely for ideological reasons. Again, a very rare thing in espionage. Most espionage is about money. Most people in that world, particularly agents, by, by cash, cold, hard cash.
我的意思是，戈尔季耶夫斯基就是一个很好的例子。我的意思是，这是一个能够通知他的主人——在这种情况下是军情六处（MI6）和中央情报局（CIA）——能够通知他们敌人正在想什么的间谍的真正好例子。这是间谍活动的关键要素。如果你能进入对手的头脑，不仅找出他在做什么，还能找出他计划做什么，你就领先了一大步。戈尔季耶夫斯基所做的是，戈尔季耶夫斯基是一名职业克格勃（KGB）官员。我的意思是，他生来就是克格勃。事实上，他是一名非常优秀的克格勃官员。他真的是随血缘而来。但在60年代的哥本哈根，他叛变了。他叛变确实几乎完全是出于意识形态原因。同样，在间谍活动中是非常罕见的事情。大多数间谍活动是关于金钱的。那个世界里的大多数人，特别是特工，为了现金，冷冰冰的现金。
That wasn't the case with Gordievsky. He decided, he's a highly intellectual man, he decided that he was serving a brutal, repressive regime, and that he really needed to, you know, that he really needed to flip to the other side. So Gordievsky was turned, and for a decade, was passing information to MI6 and the CIA that was going straight to not just Downing Street, but going to the Oval Office, it was going straight to Reagan's desk. And it is clear that some of the things he was able to reveal materially changed the way that Reagan and Thatcher perceived the Soviet Union. And in many ways, he sort of paved the way for the beginning of the end of the Cold War. And I'll give you just one example. There are two terrific examples. One is that Gordievsky ended up as the sort of designated
戈尔季耶夫斯基的情况并非如此。他决定，他是一个高度知识分子，他决定他正在为一个残酷、压迫的政权服务，他真的需要，你知道，他真的需要倒戈到另一边。所以戈尔季耶夫斯基被策反了，十年来，他一直在向军情六处和中央情报局传递信息，这些信息不仅直接传到了唐宁街，还传到了椭圆形办公室，直接传到了里根的办公桌上。很明显，他能够揭露的一些事情实质性地改变了里根和撒切尔对苏联的看法。在很多方面，他为冷战的终结铺平了道路。我只给你举一个例子。有两个极好的例子。一个是戈尔季耶夫斯基最终成为了某种指定的……
head of the KGB in Britain, which meant that he would have access to the crown jewels, really, he would have access to everything the KGB was doing in this country. And when Gorbachev visited, the famous visit in December 1984, Gorbachev's job for the KGB was to draw up a memo of what Gorbachev should say to Thatcher. Now, that memo was actually, of course, drawn up by MI6. And so you have a unique situation here where one spy is advising both sides on what to say to the other. So when Thatcher emerged from that meeting saying, this is a man we can do business with, well, there was a very simple reason for that. Gordievsky had rigged the business. I mean, the whole script had been written beforehand. So that's just an example of how, you know, and that's a small way that the sort of the minutiae of relations between states can be materially affected by espionage.
克格勃在英国的负责人，这意味着他可以接触到皇冠上的宝石，真的，他可以接触到克格勃在这个国家所做的一切。当戈尔巴乔夫访问时，1984年12月那次著名的访问，戈尔巴乔夫为克格勃的工作是起草一份戈尔巴乔夫应该对撒切尔说什么的备忘录。现在，那份备忘录实际上当然是由军情六处起草的。所以你在这里有一个独特的情况，一个间谍在建议双方对对方说什么。所以当撒切尔从那次会议出来说，“这是一个我们可以共事的人”时，嗯，有一个非常简单的原因。戈尔季耶夫斯基操纵了这件事。我的意思是，整个剧本都是事先写好的。所以这只是一个例子，说明你知道，国家之间关系的细节是如何被间谍活动实质性影响的。
But Ben, I mean, a much bigger one, and on the whole question of does spying affect things, is that it's Gordievsky, isn't it, who tips Thatcher and Reagan off that, what was it, in 1983 with Operation Archer, this NATO attempt to simulate a nuclear attack, the soviets thought that this was genuine preparation for a first nuclear strike by nato absolutely and the world came teeteringly close to to nuclear war so i mean that that then has a a seismic impact on the way that that reagan ultimately thinks yeah we've got we've got to we've got to denuclearize. Hugely important and much forgotten, actually, the whole Abel Archer story, which was terrifying, actually. I mean, some historians think, and I think there's a good argument for this, that it was the closest the world came to nuclear Armageddon since the Cuban Missile Crisis. And it's almost completely unknown these days.
但本，我的意思是，一个更大的例子，关于间谍活动是否影响事情的整个问题，是戈尔季耶夫斯基，不是吗？是他向撒切尔和里根通风报信，说那是1983年的“优秀射手”（Operation Able Archer）演习，北约试图模拟核攻击，苏联人认为这是北约进行第一次核打击的真正准备。绝对是这样，世界摇摇欲坠地接近核战争。所以我的意思是，这对里根最终的想法产生了巨大的影响，“是的，我们必须，我们必须，我们必须去核化。”极其重要，而且几乎被遗忘了，整个“优秀射手”的故事，实际上非常可怕。我的意思是，一些历史学家认为，而且我认为这有很好的论据，这是自古巴导弹危机以来世界最接近核末日的一次。而且这些天几乎完全不为人知。
It's beginning to sort of emerge. And what Gordievsky was able to explain to his handlers in London and then passed on to Washington was that this was, if you like, it was genuine paranoia on the part of the, if you can have such a thing, on the part of the Kremlin. That the Kremlin genuinely believed that this, the build up particularly to this, to this defence operation, which was just a practice run, really, was being perceived as the real thing in the Kremlin. And you can see a dramatic change in the rhetoric and the posture of Reagan and Thatcher from that moment. They realized that they were being perceived as the aggressors, which they'd never really thought of themselves as. And you can start to see a gentle thawing that then continues right to the fall of the Berlin Wall. And it's absolutely fascinating. But you can argue that Gordievsky played a signal part in making us all safer, you know, in preventing an appalling misunderstanding, if you like. And that came from being able to point
它开始浮出水面。戈尔季耶夫斯基能够向他在伦敦的联络人解释，然后传达给华盛顿的是，如果可以这样说的话，这是克里姆林宫方面的真正偏执。克里姆林宫真的相信，这次防御行动的准备工作——这实际上只是一个演习——在克里姆林宫被视为真实的事情。你可以从那一刻起看到里根和撒切尔在言辞和姿态上的巨大变化。他们意识到他们被视为侵略者，而他们从未真正这样看待过自己。你可以开始看到一种温和的解冻，然后一直持续到柏林墙倒塌。这绝对令人着迷。但你可以说，戈尔季耶夫斯基在让我们所有人更安全方面发挥了重要作用，你知道，防止了一场可怕的误解。而这来自于能够指出……
out what was actually going on inside the heads of the sort of gerontocracy that was running the Soviet Union at that point. But Gordievsky also raises a really interesting question, which is there actually in a lot of your books, certainly the Cold War ones. It's about that dividing line between the spy and the traitor. Because, I mean, Gordievsky was a traitor to his country. I mean, he's a hero to us. And he's viewed as such. And you've obviously written about Philby and Kim Philby and Agent Sonia in your most recent book. a traitor to his country. I mean, he's a hero to us, and he's viewed as such. And you've obviously written about Philby and Kim Philby and Agent Sonia in your most recent book.
当时运行苏联的老人政治内部到底在发生什么。但戈尔季耶夫斯基也提出了一个非常有趣的问题，这在你的很多书中确实存在，当然是冷战时期的那些。这是关于间谍和叛徒之间的那条分界线。因为，我的意思是，戈尔季耶夫斯基是他国家的叛徒。我的意思是，他是我们的英雄。他被视为如此。你显然写过菲尔比（Philby）和金·菲尔比（Kim Philby）以及你最近一本书中的索尼娅特工（Agent Sonia）。他国家的叛徒。我的意思是，他是我们的英雄。他被视为如此。你显然写过菲尔比和金·菲尔比以及你最近一本书中的索尼娅特工。
And a lot of these people, I mean, what's fascinating about them to me is they're so ambiguous. Are they heroes or are they, you know, how do you deal with that? Well, yes. I mean, I think that, yes, I mean, our hero is their traitor. Their traitor is our hero. It's, I mean, Gordievsky himself would utterly reject the notion that he betrayed anybody. But his KGB colleagues, many of whom I interviewed for that book, regard him as we regard Kim Philby, that he was a rank.
这些人中的许多人，我的意思是，对我来说，关于他们最迷人的是他们是如此模棱两可。他们是英雄还是，你知道，你如何处理这个问题？嗯，是的。我的意思是，我认为，是的，我的意思是，我们的英雄是他们的叛徒。他们的叛徒是我们的英雄。我的意思是，戈尔季耶夫斯基本人会完全拒绝他背叛了任何人的概念。但他的克格勃同事，我为那本书采访了其中的许多人，他们看待他就像我们看待金·菲尔比一样，他是一个……
Whatever you felt about the regime, their argument is on a human level. I mean, many of them said to me, look, we all felt that the Soviet Union was troubled. It was all going down the pan. But only Gordievsky decided to betray. Only he decided to turn around. And so the ambivalence in that title is completely intentional, that the spy on the train. I think there is a distinction to be made, though. And in the end, I mean, Philby and Gordievsky are the obvious comparisons. There is a difference, though. And the difference in the end is a sort of moral one. Kim Philby was serving a brutal, repressive Stalinist regime that was murdering millions
无论你对那个政权有什么感觉，他们的论点是在人类层面上。我的意思是，他们中的许多人对我说，看，我们都觉得苏联有问题。一切都在走下坡路。但只有戈尔季耶夫斯基决定背叛。只有他决定倒戈。所以那个标题中的矛盾是完全故意的，间谍与叛徒。不过，我认为确实需要做出区分。最后，我的意思是，菲尔比和戈尔季耶夫斯基是显而易见的比较。不过，确实有区别。而最终的区别是一种道德上的区别。金·菲尔比服务于一个残酷、压迫的斯大林主义政权，该政权谋杀了数百万人……
of people. And he knew it. I mean, he was in a unique position, Kim Philby, as an MI6 officer on the Soviet desk, to know what was really happening. He couldn't claim ignorance about what was going on. Gordievsky had seen both sides, and he too, he came, well, he, in sharp contradistinction, decided that one side was on the side of right, and one wasn't. So there is an important moral distinction in the Cold War. And then there is a sort of much more practical element, which is that Philby was responsible for the deaths of many, many hundreds of people. He knew that the people he was tipping off, the Soviets, too, were going to be executed. They weren't even going to be tried. Gordievsky made it a central part of his agreement to work for MI6
的人。而且他知道。我的意思是，金·菲尔比作为苏联部门的军情六处官员，处于一个独特的位置，知道到底发生了什么。他不能声称对正在发生的事情一无所知。戈尔季耶夫斯基看到了双方，他也，他来到，嗯，他，与此形成鲜明对比的是，决定了一方站在正义的一边，而另一方没有。所以冷战中有一个重要的道德区别。然后还有一个更实际的因素，那就是菲尔比对成百上千人的死亡负有责任。他知道他通风报信的人，苏联人，也将被处决。他们甚至不会受到审判。戈尔季耶夫斯基将他为军情六处工作的协议的核心部分定为……
that there would be no bloodshed as a result of what he was doing. And so there are different systems. The people that Gordievsky identified to the West as being Soviet moles were tracked, they were eventually arrested, they were tried, and in some cases, they were put in prison. On the other side, those that were identified by Philby and others working for the Soviet Union were rounded up, tortured, and shot. I mean, so there is a practical difference in that as well. Ben, I feel we're almost just skimming the surface here, but we're already tight for a break.
他所做的事情不会导致流血。所以有不同的系统。戈尔季耶夫斯基向西方指认的苏联鼹鼠被追踪，他们最终被逮捕，他们受到审判，在某些情况下，他们被关进监狱。在另一边，那些被菲尔比和其他为苏联工作的人指认的人被围捕、折磨并枪杀。我的意思是，所以在这方面也有实际的区别。本，我觉得我们在这里几乎只是触及了表面，但我们已经没时间了，要休息一下了。
So we're going to have a short interlude, and then we'll come back. And I've got a question for you following on from that what you were just talking about I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
所以我们将有一个简短的插曲，然后我们会回来。我有一个问题要问你，接着你刚才谈到的内容。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论……
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are with Ben McIntyre. We're talking about the history of espionage. And Ben, before the break, you were talking about the ideological dimension of spying. And does that add something extra to the mix on top of national rivalries? Because I'm thinking the early modern period, the heyday of spying then was Francis Walsingham, Elizabeth I, Spymaster. And that, of course, is the great rivalry between Catholics and Protestants. And what you get i guess with the the communist revolution in russia is the sense of a great titanic struggle between communism and the capitalist world does that kind of really soup up espionage in a way that that perhaps it hadn't been before in the 19th and even in the
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们和本·麦金泰尔在一起。我们正在谈论间谍史。本，休息前，你谈到了间谍活动的意识形态维度。这是否在国家竞争之上为混合物增加了一些额外的东西？因为我在想近代早期，那时间谍活动的鼎盛时期是弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆（Francis Walsingham），伊丽莎白一世，间谍大师。当然，那是天主教徒和新教徒之间的伟大竞争。我想你在俄罗斯共产主义革命中得到的是一种共产主义与资本主义世界之间伟大泰坦式斗争的感觉，这是否真的以一种在19世纪甚至在……
first world war period undoubtedly because you have these two you have a sort of manichean that perhaps it hadn't been before in the 19th and even in the First World War period? Undoubtedly, because you have these two, you have a sort of Manichean struggle between these two world ideologies, but it's, let's be honest, bent on world domination. I mean, you've got, when the stakes don't get much higher and thrown into the mix in the Cold War, you also have the possibility of global annihilation added in as well. So you've got, you know, the stakes are incredibly high. And it's one of the interesting things really about modern espionage is that although it does have an ideological dimension, that's, you know, we talk about Islamic fundamentalism and so on, but much, as it were, domestic intelligence is really about nationalism now.
第一次世界大战时期可能没有的方式加强了间谍活动？毫无疑问，因为你有这两个，你有一种摩尼教式的斗争，在这些世界意识形态之间，但让我们诚实地说，致力于世界统治。我的意思是，你拥有，当赌注没有更高的时候，在冷战中加入混合物，你还增加了全球毁灭的可能性。所以你拥有，你知道，赌注高得令人难以置信。现代间谍活动的一个有趣之处在于，虽然它确实有一个意识形态维度，那是，你知道，我们谈论伊斯兰原教旨主义等等，但很多，可以说，国内情报现在确实是关于民族主义的。
It's about the projection of sort of power by other means. It's not really a massive ideological cleavage. I mean, Alexander, Alex Younger, recently, former head of MI6 was saying, you know, Russia is the main threat. And that is probably right in an espionage world. But it's not really an ideological conflict. It's about projection of power and influence and economics in a huge way. So I think, yes, I mean, one has to be a bit careful of ideology, though, because we were talking about Kim Philby, and Kim Philby was famously the most infamous of the Cambridge Five spies. And he was a communist as a young man who had signed up in the 30s with the predecessor of
这是关于通过其他手段投射某种力量。这并不是一个巨大的意识形态分裂。我的意思是，亚历山大·亚历山大·扬格（Alex Younger），最近，前军情六处负责人说，你知道，俄罗斯是主要威胁。这在间谍世界中可能是对的。但这并不是真正的意识形态冲突。这是关于权力和影响力的投射，以及在很大程度上是经济。所以我认为，是的，我的意思是，一个人必须对意识形态有点小心，因为我们刚才在谈论金·菲尔比，金·菲尔比是剑桥五人组间谍中最臭名昭著的。他年轻时是一名共产主义者，在30年代加入了……
the KGB and then did unbelievable damage to MI6. And he always painted himself as a sort of ideological warrior and crusader. It's not quite accurate that. I mean, he certainly he was a committed communist to begin with. But over time, many other influences, and this is true of many spies, came to inform the way he behaved. And they included hubris, ambition, and the drug of espionage. I mean, the drug of secrecy is a very strong one. It's very toxic, and it's very difficult to give up once you've tasted it. And, you know, a sort of certain macabre love of adventure, too, and a kind of a resilience and a sort of, somebody once described
克格勃的前身，然后对军情六处造成了难以置信的破坏。他总是把自己描绘成某种意识形态战士和十字军。那不太准确。我的意思是，他当然，他一开始是一名坚定的共产主义者。但随着时间的推移，许多其他影响，这对于许多间谍来说都是真实的，开始影响他的行为方式。它们包括傲慢、野心和间谍活动的毒品。我的意思是，秘密的毒品是非常强烈的。它非常有毒，一旦你尝过它就很难放弃。而且，你知道，某种阴森的冒险爱好，以及一种韧性和某种，有人曾经描述过……
it as the ruthless exercise of private power. I think that is, I think that comes very close to describing a lot of the motivation, which is outwith any kind of ideological commitment. And it's my firm conviction that by the time he was actually, he sort of went into exile in Moscow, by the time he escaped Kim Philby,
它作为私人权力的无情行使。我认为那是，我认为这非常接近描述很多动机，这超出了任何形式的意识形态承诺。我坚信，当他实际上，他某种程度上流亡到莫斯科时，当他逃脱时，金·菲尔比，
he really didn't believe in communism anymore. It was, he was just, He was just hooked on the game and couldn't give it up and the romance of it. So again, in a way, that takes us back to the whole, it's an imaginative business, espionage. And once you've sucked yourself into that story, and you've become, as it were, an actor in your own drama're it's very hard to stop so i think it's well while there are ideological spies they're quite rare um gordievsky is a good example he's someone who still today exudes a kind of sense of his own moral rectitude in doing in doing what he did that he feels he was on the side of right it doesn't make him it's sometimes an easy character
他真的不再相信共产主义了。它是，他只是，他只是迷上了这个游戏，无法放弃，以及它的浪漫。所以同样，在某种程度上，这把我们带回了整体，间谍活动是一项富有想象力的业务。一旦你把自己吸进那个故事，并且你已经成为，可以说，你自己戏剧中的演员，就很难停止了。所以我认为，虽然有意识形态间谍，但他们相当罕见。嗯，戈尔季耶夫斯基是一个很好的例子，他是一个即使在今天也散发出一种他在做他所做的事情时的道德正直感的人，他觉得他站在正义的一边。这并不让他，有时是一个容易相处的人……
to deal with because zealots are often not easy companions. But he's very rare. I mean, those people who are purely motivated by a belief are hen's teeth in this world. All the people we've talked about so far, Ben, have been men. But obviously there's a huge fascination with female spies, the kind of Matter Harry archetype and the sort of James Bond, you know, the spy who loved me, this sort of glamorous agent. And your most recent book, Agent Sonia, is about a woman who's not
因为狂热者通常不是容易的同伴。但他非常罕见。我的意思是，那些纯粹被信仰驱动的人在这个世界上是凤毛麟角。本，到目前为止我们谈论的所有人都是男性。但显然人们对女性间谍有巨大的迷恋，那种玛塔·哈里（Mata Hari）原型和那种詹姆斯·邦德，你知道，那个爱我的间谍，那种迷人的特工。你最近的书《索尼娅特工》是关于一个不是……
I think a terribly glamorous character. Are women more effective? Dominic, we should name check a JHGS, one of the on Twitter who has actually asked us on that. Exact question. Which female spies in history?
我认为是一个非常迷人的角色。女性更有效吗？多米尼克，我们应该提到推特上的JHGS，他实际上问了我们这个问题。历史上的哪些女性间谍？
Well, he says which female spies deserve to be depicted in film. And maybe, you know, maybe Agent Sonia would make a great film. But my question was really, do women make better spies because they're less likely to be suspected, do you think? Because people tend to, our archetypes are so often male. Well, that is undoubtedly the case of agent, about agent Sonia, whose real name was Ursula Kaczynski. She's, her story is absolutely extraordinary because yes, there have been women spies throughout history from Mata Hari onwards. They, and before actually, but they tend to be agents. They tend to be people recruited by men to do a specific job. You know, they're couriers, and this is true of the SOE agents in the Second World War. You know,
嗯，他说哪些女性间谍值得在电影中被描绘。也许，你知道，也许索尼娅特工会成为一部伟大的电影。但我的问题真的是，女性是否因为不太可能被怀疑而成为更好的间谍，你认为呢？因为人们倾向于，我们的原型通常是男性的。嗯，关于索尼娅特工，她的真名是乌苏拉·库琴斯基（Ursula Kaczynski），这无疑是事实。她的故事绝对是非凡的，因为是的，历史上一直有女性间谍，从玛塔·哈里开始。她们，实际上在此之前也有，但她们往往是特工。她们往往是被男人招募来做特定工作的人。你知道，她们是信使，二战中的特别行动执行处（SOE）特工也是如此。你知道，
they are, what makes Ursula Kaczynski, Agent Sonia, different is that she was a pro. She was a professional intelligence officer trained by the Red Army, and she regarded it as a career. She, you know, she rose to become a colonel in the Red Army Intelligence Service, not an organization noted for its equal opportunities policies. And I don't, in her case, baking scones in a tiny village in the Cotswolds, was not going to be suspected of being a sort of super spy. And she played that card ruthlessly and absolutely brilliantly because when MI5 did finally get around to realizing that something was going on, they picked up the radio signal. She built a very powerful radio transmitter in the privy in the back garden. And the radio interception service was picking up the signals. And they did eventually come to interview her. And she was absolutely brilliant. I mean, these two men with long mustaches and trillby hats turned up at the front door, and she knew exactly who they were and what they were up
她们是，是什么让乌苏拉·库琴斯基，索尼娅特工，与众不同的是她是一名职业选手。她是一名由红军训练的职业情报官员，她将其视为一种职业。她，你知道，她晋升为红军情报局的上校，那可不是一个以平等机会政策而闻名的组织。而且我不，在她的案例中，在科茨沃尔德的一个小村庄里烤烤饼，是不会被怀疑是某种超级间谍的。她无情且绝对出色地打出了那张牌，因为当军情五处最终意识到发生了什么时，他们接收到了无线电信号。她在后花园的厕所里建造了一个非常强大的无线电发射器。无线电拦截服务正在接收信号。他们最终确实来采访她了。而且她绝对出色。我的意思是，这两个留着长胡子、戴着软呢帽的男人出现在前门，她完全知道他们是谁，他们在干什么。
to. And she said, Oh, should I get my husband, she said, and went back to sort of baking a birthday cake, which she'd been making. And the MI5 report as a result of that meeting is utterly brilliant and very funny in retrospect, because it says, well, it can't possibly be Mrs. Burton, because she's far too busy with her domestic duties to be involved in any kind of espionage. And Ursula knew exactly what she was doing. I mean, she's very funny about it. So, Ben, presumably the best spies are the ones who are not going to be featuring in your books because we don't know who they are.
她说，哦，我要不要叫我丈夫？然后她回去继续烤她一直在做的生日蛋糕。事后看来，MI5（军情五处）关于那次会面的报告非常精彩且十分有趣，因为它写道，不可能是伯顿夫人，因为她忙于家务，不可能参与任何形式的间谍活动。厄休拉非常清楚自己在做什么。我的意思是，她对此感到非常有趣。所以，本，大概最好的间谍是那些不会出现在你的书里的人，因为我们根本不知道他们是谁。
I mean, would be the kind of logical implication of that. Well, you're right, actually. Well, we're talking, there are so many different sorts of spies. I mean, if you're talking about sleepers, if you're talking about, as it were, what the Russians used to refer to as illegals, people who are implanted in foreign countries under usually under civilian cover, in order to sort of absorb into the local populace and then be deployed. And everyone does this. I mean, the Russians were particularly good at it. They had a whole section of the Ljubljana that was used to create false identities to implant people in foreign countries. And some of your listeners will have watched the Americans until the present day, you know, there are sleepers among us. They come in different forms. It's not quite the same. It's not it's not there isn't that rigid ideological iron curtain that you need to get around in order to plant your spies. But believe me, they're among us. And Gordievsky is of the view that there are more illegal spies of different shapes and sorts operating in the West than at any time including the height of the cold war we've got um two questions i'd like to pair one from calvin
我的意思是，这在逻辑上是必然的。嗯，你说得对。我们谈论的是，间谍有很多种。如果你谈论的是潜伏者，如果你谈论的是俄罗斯人过去所说的“非法人员”，即那些通常以平民身份潜入外国，为了融入当地民众并随时待命的人。每个人都这样做。俄罗斯人在这方面特别擅长。他们有一个专门的部门负责制造虚假身份，将人员安插到外国。你们中的一些听众可能看过《美国谍梦》，直到今天，你知道，我们中间确实有潜伏者。他们以不同的形式存在。这不完全一样。没有那种你需要绕过的僵化的意识形态铁幕来安插间谍。但相信我，他们就在我们中间。戈尔季耶夫斯基认为，在西方活动的各种非法间谍比以往任何时候都多，包括冷战最激烈的时期。我们有两个问题想合并一下，一个来自卡尔文。
and he asked what are the examples from history if any where spies made a definitive difference to a war course of history and we've kind of touched on that already but then there's um there is uh um there's also one from arif uh mahmoud who asks, how important was spy Kermit Roosevelt Jr.? Historian Hugh Wilford describes him as being among the most important intelligence officers of their generation in the Middle East. Kermit Roosevelt Jr., I think, was the grandson of? Grandson. Yes, grandson. And key player in the American kind of establishment of American supremacy in the Middle East.
他问，历史上是否有间谍对战争进程产生决定性影响的例子？我们之前已经谈到过这一点，但还有一个来自阿里夫·马哈茂德的问题，他问，间谍克米特·罗斯福（Kermit Roosevelt Jr.）有多重要？历史学家休·威尔福德（Hugh Wilford）形容他是中东那一代最重要的情报官员之一。克米特·罗斯福，我想，是……的孙子？孙子。是的，孙子。他是美国在中东确立霸权的关键人物。
Yeah. And the reason I ask that I pair those is that there is obviously a temptation, if you were looking for spies, to find them, and perhaps to overemphasize the role that they play. And I guess that MI6 had this reputation, perhaps up to the 50s, maybe in Iran still does. And the CIA definitely does. The idea that everything that happens in the world happens because people in Langley are pulling strings. That's right. There's a hidden hand behind everything. And you're right. I mean, one shouldn't look for... Yes, I mean, I think that one has to take that into perspective.
是的。我把这两个问题放在一起问的原因是，如果你在寻找间谍，很容易会发现他们，甚至可能过分强调他们所扮演的角色。我想军情六处（MI6）在50年代之前，甚至在伊朗可能至今都有这种名声。中央情报局（CIA）肯定有。那种认为世界上发生的一切都是因为兰利（CIA总部）的人在幕后操纵的想法。没错。每件事背后都有一只看不见的手。你是对的。我的意思是，人们不应该去寻找……是的，我认为必须从客观角度来看待这个问题。
Just to answer the first question, I mean, one of the sort of world changing events, and I should have mentioned when we were talking about the wartime stuff is the Bletchley Park intelligence operation, because of course, that was a dramatic, had a dramatic impact on the way the war was fought. And the way the war was shortened, it's still debated how much it was shortened by, but there's little doubt that it shortened the course of the war. That's a brilliant example of when intelligence really does matter. You know, it makes a huge difference. Of course, that's a different kind of intelligence from what we were talking about. We were talking about human intelligence, which is individuals dealing with other individuals and extracting secrets from them or misleading them. Signals intelligence,
回答第一个问题，我的意思是，改变世界的事件之一，我在谈论战时事务时应该提到布莱切利园的情报行动，因为当然，那对战争的打法产生了戏剧性的影响。以及战争缩短的方式，虽然关于它缩短了多少时间仍有争论，但毫无疑问它缩短了战争进程。这是一个情报确实至关重要的绝佳例子。你知道，它产生了巨大的影响。当然，那与我们谈论的情报类型不同。我们谈论的是人力情报，即个人与个人打交道，从他们那里获取秘密或误导他们。信号情报，
which is what Bletchley Park is, and what is the preponderant form of intelligence today, is about messages. Today, it's about emails and texts and intercepting, you know, Facebook messages and so on. The Roosevelt story is very interesting. I mean, Kermit Roosevelt was very important. It's certainly particularly important in a pretty ugly, I think, sort of episode of history, which is the toppling of Prime Minister Mossadegh in Iran, the consequences of which we are still living with today. And if you want to know why the Iranians feel so strongly about Britain, it really does go back to the entirely justified belief that a democratically elected leader was deliberately ousted by a CIA MI6 combined plot. And it's a
也就是布莱切利园所做的，也是当今最主要的情报形式，是关于信息的。今天，它是关于电子邮件、短信、拦截Facebook消息等等。罗斯福的故事非常有趣。我的意思是，克米特·罗斯福非常重要。他在一段我认为相当丑陋的历史插曲中尤其重要，那就是推翻伊朗总理摩萨台，我们至今仍在承受其后果。如果你想知道为什么伊朗人对英国有如此强烈的感情，这确实可以追溯到他们完全合理的信念，即一位民主选举产生的领导人是被CIA和MI6联合策划故意赶下台的。这是一个
pretty disgraceful episode in many ways. I mean, again, one can't indulge in what history, but it did not have the effect that the West wanted it to have. And eventually it drove Iran in a completely different direction. So yes, he was important, but perhaps not in a way that one would necessarily want to celebrate. It's quite interesting that those files have yet to be released on exactly what MI6 and the CIA were up to and the extent to which they were involved. And you say that, you know, that there is a tendency to over-celebrate spies. And that is undoubtedly true. But there is a real conflict within the intelligence world itself about whether these stories should be told at all. Because of course, MI6, like the SAS,
在许多方面都相当可耻的插曲。我的意思是，同样，人们不能沉溺于“如果历史”，但它并没有产生西方想要的效果。最终，它将伊朗推向了一个完全不同的方向。所以是的，他很重要，但也许不是以人们想要庆祝的方式。很有趣的是，关于MI6和CIA到底在做什么以及他们参与程度的文件尚未解密。你说，你知道，有一种过度赞美间谍的倾向。这无疑是真的。但在情报界内部，关于这些故事是否应该被讲述，确实存在真正的冲突。因为当然，MI6就像SAS（特种空勤团）一样，
trades on its own secrecy. It's the idea that you're not going to find out what it's really up to, because that's how it recruits more people. And that's how it engages agents who believe they're never going to be exposed in their story, they're never going to come out. But that conflicts with the fact that they're frightfully proud of what they do. And also, they have some great stories to tell. MI5, the Internal Security Service, is much more open about its past. It's much more prepared. I mean, it is indeed prepared to declassify its files. MI6 never declassifies its files. There is no declassified MI6 archive anywhere. But the time is coming, I suspect, when, you know, this sort of like conflict within sort of the intelligence philosophy itself is going to be writ large because we don't really like secrecy anymore.
以自身的保密性为生。这是一种你永远不会发现它真正意图的想法，因为这就是它招募更多人的方式。这也是它吸引那些相信自己永远不会被曝光、故事永远不会被公开的特工的方式。但这与他们对自己所做的事情感到非常自豪的事实相冲突。而且，他们确实有一些很棒的故事要讲。MI5，内部安全局，对过去要开放得多。它准备得更充分。我的意思是，它确实准备好将其文件解密。MI6从不解密其文件。没有任何地方有解密的MI6档案。但我怀疑，当这种情报哲学内部的冲突因为我们不再真正喜欢保密而变得显而易见时，这一天终会到来。
We don't approve of secrecy and we associate people keeping secrets with people having something to hide. And so I think eventually MI6 will be forced to put all of this out there. I mean, there's a sort of selective attitude to it. I mean, they were very interesting about the Gordievsky story, of course, which was an MI6 run operation. And while they would not let me see the files, despite begging on my part for a long time, they were prepared to let me interview every single MI6 agent who was involved in that story, which technically they're not supposed to do. I mean, in theory, each one of them was breaking the Official Secrets Act. Hey, you know, it's a story
我们不赞成保密，我们将保守秘密的人与有隐情的人联系在一起。所以我认为最终MI6将被迫公开这一切。我的意思是，他们对此有一种选择性的态度。我的意思是，他们对戈尔季耶夫斯基的故事非常感兴趣，当然，那是一次由MI6领导的行动。虽然他们不让我看文件，尽管我恳求了很久，但他们准备让我采访每一个参与那个故事的MI6特工，这在技术上是不被允许的。我的意思是，理论上，他们每个人都在违反《官方机密法》。嘿，你知道，这是一个
that MI6, oddly enough, rather likes, because it really works for MI6. Had they not achieved what they had achieved, you would never have heard of Oleg Gordievsky. And Ben, looking further forward, we've got a good question from the Lundy Project. He says, or he or she says, in the 20th century, spying was all about human capital. So there's your Gordievsky's and your Agent Sonia and your Operation Mincemeat and so on. So it's all about individual human beings who you've got on your side, who you're trying to turn and all that kind of thing. And the only project says basically is that dead with cyber warfare? Is espionage now basically rows of people sitting behind desks in open plan offices kind of tapping away?
MI6奇怪地相当喜欢的故事，因为它确实对MI6有效。如果他们没有取得那样的成就，你永远不会听说奥列格·戈尔季耶夫斯基。本，展望未来，我们有一个来自Lundy Project的好问题。他说，或者她（他）说，在20世纪，间谍活动完全是关于人力资本的。所以有你的戈尔季耶夫斯基、索尼娅特工、肉馅行动等等。所以这一切都是关于你站在你这一边的个体，你试图策反他们等等。Lundy Project基本上说，网络战是否终结了这一切？间谍活动现在基本上是人们坐在开放式办公室的桌子后面敲键盘吗？
There is no doubt that the lead intelligence agency in this country, as it is in most countries, is now GCHQ or the equivalents. You know, that is where the hard grind is being done. Although I was incredibly flattered. I was given a tour of GCHQ the other day. And one of the programs they have for training people on how to create false identities online, which course, you can do. I mean, we imagine that it's the same process, really. You can create an avatar online. In fact, in some ways, it's much easier to do. You can give them a backstory. You can give them a false history.
毫无疑问，这个国家，就像大多数国家一样，领先的情报机构现在是GCHQ（政府通信总部）或其同类机构。你知道，那是艰苦工作所在的地方。虽然我感到非常荣幸。前几天我参观了GCHQ。他们有一个培训人们如何在网上创建虚假身份的项目，当然，你可以做到。我的意思是，我们想象这实际上是同一个过程。你可以在网上创建一个化身。事实上，在某些方面，这更容易做到。你可以给他们一个背景故事。你可以给他们一个虚假的历史。
You can give them Facebook. You can give them – it's called, to my intense pleasure, it's called Operation Mincemeat, the training module that they go through to try and create these things. But no, yes, I mean, signals intelligence, SIGINT, is now the lead operation. But signals intelligence doesn't really work without human intelligence. And human intelligence is a vital adjunct to signals intelligence. So let's go back to the war again.
你可以给他们Facebook。你可以给他们——令我非常高兴的是，它被称为“肉馅行动”，这是他们为了尝试创造这些东西而进行的培训模块。但不，是的，我的意思是，信号情报（SIGINT）现在是主要的行动。但信号情报如果没有人力情报真的无法工作。人力情报是信号情报的重要补充。所以让我们回到战争。
The Bletchley Park secret was a signals intelligence victory, but it was achieved by human intelligence, by individuals, in many cases, stealing the secrets, the enigma secrets in order to do it. And the same is true today. You still need human intelligence. It doesn't really work without human intelligence. So say, you know, you know, that there's a particular individual in RACA who is who is using his mobile phone to send messages that you need to break into. You still need someone in Raqqa to identify him. You still need somebody in that cafe able to say, it's that guy over there. He's on the phone now.
布莱切利园的秘密是一次信号情报的胜利，但它是通过人力情报实现的，在许多情况下，是个体窃取了秘密，即恩尼格玛密码秘密才做到的。今天也是如此。你仍然需要人力情报。没有人力情报，它真的无法工作。所以说，你知道，拉卡（Raqqa）有一个特定的人正在使用他的手机发送你需要破解的信息。你仍然需要拉卡有人来识别他。你仍然需要咖啡馆里的某个人能够说，就是那边的那个家伙。他现在正在打电话。
So the human and the technological always intertwine. And although it's a strange rivalry within intelligence, you know, the human people don't really like the singing people and it's a ridiculous kind of, it's a ridiculous rivalry, as it is between MI5 and MI6. Nonetheless, they all admit when they're in calmer moments that they can't operate without each other. And so increasingly, intelligence officers in this country and around the world are expected to be able to do the technical stuff as well as the human stuff. You've got to have both. So the idea of this
所以人力和技术总是交织在一起的。虽然情报界内部存在一种奇怪的竞争，你知道，人力部门的人不太喜欢信号部门的人，这是一种荒谬的竞争，就像MI5和MI6之间一样。尽管如此，他们在冷静的时候都承认，没有对方他们就无法运作。因此，这个国家的以及世界各地的情报官员越来越多地被要求既能做技术工作，也能做人力工作。你必须两者兼备。所以这种专业化的想法
specialization is really going, I think. And modern spies, they can all code, believe me. They understand their way around the inside of a computer. And it's quite interesting the way that the two elements are no longer, I think, distinct in lots of ways. They are regarded as one portmanteau skill, if you like. And is there a particular spy story that has never been told that you would love to tell, that you think matters? He can't tell, Dominic, or he'll be shocked. I can't, Fred, I can't tell you because I'd have to, well, obviously I'd have to kill you.
真的要消失了，我想。现代间谍，相信我，他们都会编程。他们了解计算机内部的运作方式。这两个要素在很多方面不再是截然不同的，这很有趣。如果你愿意的话，它们被视为一种组合技能。有没有一个从未被讲述过的、你很想讲述的、你认为很重要的间谍故事？他不能说，多米尼克，否则他会被杀的。我不能，弗雷德，我不能告诉你，因为我不得不……好吧，显然我不得不杀了你。
Look, I think there are, I know there are actually, there are plenty of Cold War stories that haven't yet come out. The very fact that we don't know them is probably evidence that they're really very good, you know, and I don't think Gordievsky was alone. I know he wasn't. I know there were characters on both sides who were who were having a similar impact it's difficult though because as i've said finding the finding the documentary material for this stuff the more modern you get the harder it
看，我认为有，我实际上知道有，有很多冷战故事还没有出来。我们不知道它们这一事实本身可能就是它们非常好的证据，你知道，我不认为戈尔季耶夫斯基是唯一的。我知道他不是。我知道双方都有人物在产生类似的影响。但这很困难，因为正如我所说，寻找这些东西的文献资料，你越现代，就越
is to lay your hands on and to write sort of narrative non-fiction stories which you kindly said at the beginning you know i try to make feel like novels, but yet they are completely true. I never make anything up. It's not a word that is invented in there. If I say the sky was blue that day, the sky was blue that day because I know it. That's harder, much harder in the modern times, because I rely very heavily on letters and postcards and poems and diaries and photographs and all that kind of tangible stuff that allows
难上手，也越难写出那种你开头好心说的我试图让它感觉像小说的叙事性非虚构故事，但它们却是完全真实的。我从不编造任何东西。里面没有一个词是虚构的。如果我说那天天空是蓝色的，那天天空就是蓝色的，因为我知道。这在现代更难，难得多，因为我非常依赖信件、明信片、诗歌、日记、照片和所有那些让我能够
one to do the sort of warp and weft of the daily life of these people. In modern times, you know, it's going to be really hard for historians of the future, I think, particularly intelligence historians, to try to get the material because nobody writes it down in the same way. The evidence isn't there. And one of the impacts, and one has to admit this, of a more declassified world where these secrets are coming out is that the intelligence services weed their files really carefully. Or don't write it down, I suppose. Or don't write it down. Or a lot of it is in very ephemeral form. I mean, we imagine that every text message we send and every email we receive
进行这些人的日常生活经纬编织的有形事物。在现代，你知道，对于未来的历史学家，我认为特别是情报历史学家来说，试图获取这些材料将非常困难，因为没有人以同样的方式写下来。证据不存在。而且，一个更加透明的世界（指解密）带来的影响之一，人们必须承认这一点，就是情报部门非常仔细地清理他们的文件。或者我想是不写下来。或者不写下来。或者很多是以非常短暂的形式存在的。我的意思是，我们想象我们发送的每一条短信和收到的每一封电子邮件
is somehow being archived, but it's not, you know. And so, you know, there isn't, I'm so lucky in a way because the period that I cover, you know, there's almost always a box in the attic filled with something that somebody can let me get my mitts on and then plunder. That's not going to be the case because none of us keep our emails, none of us keep our, and getting hold of them will be very very difficult so so the more modern it gets really the tougher it becomes to tell these stories with the kind of with the detail that makes them work i hope i think that that's probably a slightly if you're a historian
都在以某种方式被存档，但事实并非如此，你知道。所以，你知道，没有……我在某种程度上很幸运，因为我所涵盖的时期，你知道，阁楼里几乎总有一个装满东西的盒子，有人可以让我拿到手，然后掠夺。这种情况不会再发生了，因为我们没有人保留我们的电子邮件，没有人保留我们的……而且获取它们将非常非常困难。所以越现代，用那种使它们生效的细节来讲述这些故事就越困难。我希望……我想这可能是一个稍微……如果你是一位历史学家，
a depressing note on which to end but perfect note on which to end so if we're going to write the history of espionage uh don't start now would probably probably look further back get cracking to the earlier stuff no look i mean it will be declassified but it will require different skills i think i mean it will it you know it won't be quite the same flood of material that you get in the second world war which was a highly literate war i mean everybody wrote everything down it's one of the wonderful things about it um you know but everyone said this is the telephone oh no one's going to be impossible to do the history of the 1980s or the 90s dominic has proved that's complete nonsense because you know because of
这是一个令人沮丧的结尾，但却是一个完美的结尾。所以如果我们打算写间谍史，现在不要开始，可能会……可能往回看，去研究早期的东西。不，看，我的意思是它会被解密，但这需要不同的技能，我想。我的意思是，它不会像第二次世界大战那样有大量的材料，那是一场高度识字率的战争，我的意思是每个人都把一切写了下来，这是它美妙的地方之一。嗯，你知道，但每个人都说这是电话，哦，没有人会去写20世纪80年代或90年代的历史，这太不可能了。多米尼克已经证明那是完全胡说八道，因为你知道，因为
the telephone no one's ever going to write anything down we still write it all down there's still a record of sorts it's just a different sword my books will be twice as long if the telephone hadn't been a terrifying thought and i think the perfect note on which to thank ben very much um we will be back when we'll be back we'll be back on thursday won't we um no we won't we'll be back on monday thanks ever so much for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
电话，没有人会写下任何东西。我们仍然把一切都写下来，仍然有某种记录，只是种类不同。如果电话没有出现，我的书会是现在的两倍长，这是一个可怕的想法。我认为这是一个感谢本的完美结尾。嗯，我们会回来的，我们什么时候回来？我们周四会回来，不是吗？嗯，不，我们不会，我们周一回来。非常感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。